thank you hi guys my name is Tamra
chambers and this is Tara's never seen
and today I am watching gremlins much
too the black nerds delight straining
out and it's making very loud clicking
noises on my window not sure if you guys
can hear that not but you're welcome if
you can anyways today I'm watching
gremlins and after tweeting about it a
bit I have come to find that gremlins 2
is the one that I really want to watch
apparently so I guess I'll watch that
maybe next Christmas I am interested in
this interested not sure about it but
here we go
oh that was a movie
so random is that the word I'm looking
for so why was this made I did not like
it I just felt like it's so weird very
dark which I like and like dark
Christmas movies Krampus
so it opens up on the dad character who
initially seems like a detective but no
even better
she sells useless kitschy bathroom
travel supplies so I guess he's on a
business trip and he's trying to sell
his useless kitschy travel bathroom
supplies to this old man who owns a
store in a dingy basement in the middle
of Chinatown read the room buddy
he offers the storekeeper $200 for the
Mogwai but the store keepers like with
Mogwai comes great responsibility
like spider-man with the Mogwai control
no sunlight no water no eating after
midnight which sounds like a rich
housewife donek close the blinds or all
wrinkles oh I'm so hungry but I can't
eat after midnight on this new diet with
4p oh right it's after midnight
more water please Dominic that's not
wired great absolute joke it is water
maybe in it then you see the hero of the
story Billy who is late to work come on
Billy
then he gets to work and you see mrs.
deagle who you know what Billy you're
fine
come on mrs. deagle she wants to kill
Barney Billy's dog in the dryer because
he broke her snowman or something okay
we could which is the worst see what I
did there usually the way to fit the
Billy comes home you find out that
they're having some money issues and
he's kind of supporting the family and
then the dad gets home and gives him his
Christmas gift which is this gremlin
that he spent $200 on super unneeded
Christmas gifts the great excellent I
know it's like a but it's Christmas and
give him something nice and what the
movie is all about and my mom laughed
200 years of online and then hell yeah
Corey Feldman is in his movie he got
weird didn't a different name so Billy
and Corey Feldman are playing with gizmo
who is the gremlin and then they get
water on him which is one of the three
rules and he said throw four balls five
new gizmos are just jumping around being
with raffles I don't understand why
gizmo is so nice and then his little
offspring her little apples maybe it's
because the storekeeper who owned him
was just really great and was a good pet
father but why are they fed for assholes
why I why side note though Billy pears
Siddhas are so cute with their little
knickknacks that don't work she's really
supportive of him even though he makes
useless kitschy travel bathroom supplies
Billy gives one of the little assholes
to a scientist to kind of check about
see what he is I love it Billy's the
first person to do this no one else is
like this is an unknown species maybe we
should get this checked out no just
Billy was like no I know a scientist
from school then a really weird exchange
happens between Billy and cake the girl
that he wants to date take the date
adorable she's talking about suicide and
depression during the holidays which is
a real thing and he's like are you Hindu
because you don't celebrate Christmas
it's the only possible explanation for
that let me plan a date he doesn't love
remember that before you had to worry
about compatibility
solely based on looks
they're cute I love this River cut to a
menacing shot of the scientists taking
blood from the little asshole gremlin
like legitimately scary and
uncomfortable and menacing and you feel
bad for the little asshole for just like
a little sucker or guy or little douche
canoe then the scientists leaves a
sandwich at 2:30 a.m. right next to
little asshole Mogwai and I've never
seen anything but more menacingly at a
sandwich in my life and I look at
sandwiches blob Oh God then you see the
scene where they're in cocoon and
they're like weird cocoon gremlin cut
back to the scientist mr. Hanson and his
gremlin has patched out of his cocoon
and then he bites his hand then he
killed him he killed the scientist mr.
Hanson it's so dark it eats a glass
cylinder that it escapes through some
vents like this watch but then all the
one to the house hatch and then they're
just like wreaking habit have it have it
and they're like giant disgusting weird
gremlins playing darts with gizmo
attached to the dartboard then they
throw him down the laundry chute and he
is so sweet and nice I want him I have
two pet cats and I really want a pet
squirrel and a pet box and a pet rat
being Cheryl and now I want a Mogwai is
that too much to ask you guys and they
make the et reference and I have seen
Ichi and then you see one eating
Christmas cookies and it's horrifying
then a model-t thought is happening and
she just goes into primal instinct
awesome mode she blends one up and she
stabbed one she microwaved one it's
flippin awesome
I wrote yeah this is very llamas legit
one of the most underrated action stars
ever
but then Billy uses a sword to launch
went into the fire that's amazing only
white striped his left white side is
like the leader of the pack either will
do they find white stripes at the local
YMCA but he falls into a pool
so this movie is it wrapping up Billy
goes to tell the cops that they're drunk
excellent good great and they change
sweetly I quote with that anyways where
do I die
so there's thousands of grandmother's
running around causing too much of a
town and they're changing street lamps
which is a bit smarter than I thought
possible for gremlins but okay good then
the gremlins show up to mrs. deagle
house and I'll okay feel kind of bad for
her because she's just a sad lonely cat
lady in her home just hanging out the
cat and that they locked her from her
home and she dies oh my god did you do
it did this doodoo dinner so all the
grandmas go to the bar that Kate works
at and she's serving them which is why
like serving them beer just leave like
are you serving them beer gremlins are
excellent tippers don't imagine that's
true then you see the lady gremlin I
cracked up when I saw the lady gremlin
because one time we were doing this
sketch for an empty episode and I had to
dress up like a stripper of course I had
like crazy makeup drawn and like giant
hoop earrings and like this blonde wig
and I looked ridiculous and Jim was like
you kind of look like a girl gremlin for
the movie gross business stuff like I
get that reference now also that's not
nice Jim but I did I looked just like
her so true so then all the gremlins are
in the movie theater because darkness
and popcorn
honestly same Billy and Cator like easy
big book blow this shit up and only
white stripe is gates so just white
stripe against Billy which isn't going
well for Billy honestly it's too bad
that it wasn't mrs. Billy's mom against
white stripe because that would have
been a fair fight so click climb back to
the movie and wife height makes it to
dis fountain in this store and he's
going to touch water again and start all
of this over but gizmo save the day by
turning on a super bright light and it's
disgusting
white stripe is like deteriorating and
the puppetry is really cool and
horrifying it's a horrific so
everything's kind of resolves as the
town is still completely destroyed but
they're gone and the oldest shopkeeper
comes back to take his bow he shaded the
white man he's like you are not ready
it's awesome
so it's a very end Billy's dad gives the
old shopkeeper smokeless ashtray is like
a I'm sorry
and the shopkeepers like it's very
generous of you but honestly the
shopkeeper had to go through so much to
get back gizmo like easily he said the
$200 that he gave him and just in travel
to go get him back off of the whole town
of Detroit so the smokeless ashtray Wow
a nice sentiment is it shipped and then
my closing statement this is just to two
remarks so dark mama so betta yeah it
was cool I like dark Christmas movies it
was super fun I really want to see to
Nell since people are like yeah I want
is whatever but too is really where it's
at yeah I went up the studio we were
filming the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
to review with a nerve and the black
nerd and Andre was like gremlins have
you seen grandma white grandmas do
grandmas have you seen it gremlins okay
great so this one's for you Andre
this is next week I'm doing a
collaboration with Jim which I'm very
excited about it yesterday I posted a
video on my personal channel Tamara L
chambers at youtube.com so check that
out if you like things and myself and
I'll see you guys next week bye
[Music]